welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and stranger things season 4
reminded us all it's still a thing with
another cryptic teaser that confirms how
wrong it is to call people not related
to you papa
good morning children
that is why i order my pizza from just
john's
i'm gonna break down all the clues both
in this teaser
and the corresponding h l control room
clip what all the numbers mean and how
it all connects with the leftover
mysteries from season three
spoiler warning in case my theories are
right but if not i don't care because
it's more fun to be surprised right so
season three ended with the kids
fighting the mind flayer in the star
court mall
while joyce and hopper closed the rift
to the upside down
leading to hopper's apparent death but a
post credits
him scene in kamchatcha russia with
another demogorgon hinted at some
american in another cell and then in
february 2020
a from russia with love teaser confirmed
hopper was still alive
in a russian labor camp and that video's
description by the way was 01
of 004 this new teaser is 02 of 004
perhaps signaling that this is the
second of four promos that they have
planned hopper's final letter
to 11 called back his fatherly request
to leave the door open three inches
which we could also look too deeply into
as maybe a signal to
keep that portal of the upside down open
enough for me to come back
it may be possible that hopper just
survived that blast by getting sucked
into the upside down a dimension that
does
bend space perhaps between points like
indiana and siberia
explaining how he got to russia now in
late 2019 david harbor also tweeted a
string of numbers that added up to the
same number listed for murray bauman in
season three a number that when you
actually called it played the voice
recording of bomb and telling joyce
about some new
possibly hopper related development you
have reached the residence
of murray bauman and mrs joyce joyce
thank you for calling i've been trying
to reach you i i have an update
it's about well it's uh it's probably
best if we speak in person it's not good
or bad but it's
something and of course a very important
loosen from season three was that eleven
seems to have lost her powers
and now the season four teaser appears
to be a flashback to 11's past
experimentation with the other test
subjects in the hawkins lab which might
correspond to the different numbers that
we see
this teaser opens on a clock reading 3
o'clock which is a bit odd because
younger dr brenner greets them with good
morning children
so either this clock is wrong or these
kids are having a morning check-in at 3
a.m
which i should note is considered in
folklore to be the witching hour when
supernatural activities occur opening on
the clock also matches the clock imagery
from the very first season 4 teaser
which showed hopper's cabin in the
upside down with a clock on a tree that
struck midnight
chiming we're not in hawkins anymore
next there's this close-up of a security
camera lens showing the reflection
of the children in this game room the
two off on the right sitting playing
chess another in the bottom sitting on
another table and then another just
standing off to the left there it's a
bit tough to tell but counting from the
kids shown in this teaser there are at
least
six like the widest shot shows four
younger ones two of the three on the
left might have been the ones with the
toy cars
and the third they're joined by or the
loner off to the right might have been
the one with the magic eight ball or the
one with the blocks or the plinko
and then in addition to these two older
kids playing chess now this security
camera feed likely goes to the control
room of the h
l hawkins national lab which another
promo clip
hinted at this teaser with
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so you'll notice these screens
creepily show this same room after
some violent attack you can see blood
now on this floor the lights now
flickering that magic eight ball also
has some blood on it but there's also
something we don't see in the broader
teaser a pair of game dice
showing the numbers two and six on one
of them and five and four on the other
but
if these are resting on their sides
facing upward would be three on the
first one
and six on the second one and if you
read into this kind of thing that could
indicate maybe a season four release
date of
march 6th or june 3rd then wolfhard said
season 4 was coming next year but
june 3rd 2022 while a friday seems way
too far off for netflix to be amping up
its promotion like this
by the way that opera music in that clip
is a french title translating to when my
sweetheart returns to me from the 1786
french opera nina the returning
sweetheart could be
the demogorgon maybe that was the thing
that attacked and killed these kids
while 11 was
locked up in her room having to sense it
all happening
actually if you listen closely as
brenner walks up to the room you do
hear a kind of interdimensional purring
of a beast
but before continuing this video is
sponsored by expressvpn
are you looking to re-watch old season's
rick and morty ahead of the new season
coming out in june but your streaming
service doesn't have it well expressvpn
can help you with that kind of thing
expressvpn is a virtual private network
that encrypts your data to keep it from
being stolen or tracked and can grant
you access to blocked content
like the us version of netflix doesn't
have rick and morty but the uk netflix
does
so you can open yourself up to a whole
new library of content without having to
pay for a new streaming service
it's faster than saying show me what you
got expressvpn allows you to reroute
your connection to a server in a country
of your choice making geo-restrictions a
thing of the past expressvpn is also
helpful for preventing your online data
from being stolen or monitored without
your knowledge
i love how super easy expressvpn is to
use no confusion
no wasted time and the whole thing runs
super fast just fire up the app and
connect with just one click
it's a top-rated vpn provider rated
number one by techradar cnet and many
more
find out how you can get three months of
expressvpn for free by visiting
expressvpn.com
new rockstars or by clicking the link in
the description below the theory i've
been going with
is that maybe during the cold war the
americans began testing on kids to breed
super soldiers the soviets found out
about this and decided to rush the
testing on their own kind of crazy
experimentation like
interdimensional travel so they opened
this rift across dimensions and use this
to attack america severely in the
heartland by unleashing their bioweapon
the demogorgon
the americans respond to this attack by
doubling down on 11's attack powers and
this being the
cold war things escalate secretly from
there and yes it does look like all the
kids in the lab here have powers kind of
like
eight cali from season two now eight
does not appear in this trailer and even
the doors in the corridor go
7 9 10 11 no 8 there but presumably she
would be part of this backstory now yes
back in season 2 we kind of noticed
there are some parallels with the x-men
here
and yeah the fourth season premiere
episode title is confirmed to be the
hellfire club a nod to the x-men comics
which we know dustin is a huge fan of
apparently that will be the name of the
boy's new d d group interesting how
these two kids race these toy trucks
along the bands of the rainbow i was
thinking maybe these are wind-up toys
but notice how it's weird how good these
toys are at staying within the colors
instead of rolling in a straight
line as if they are being controlled via
telekinesis the two older kids play
chess with bird themed pieces which is
a bit odd since that control room clip
showed different chess pieces just
normal rounded ones
the magic 8 ball reads signs point two
yes
but we don't see the kid who's holding
it maybe it actually is eight here
while another kid plays with blocks
another kid plays with this plinko type
toy where the disc drops on the number
seven
making four seven and eight covered
leaving three five and six
open randomly coming up on seven this
does remind us how seven was the number
will
actually rolled when the dice fell off
the table in the very first scene of the
series which lucas said didn't count but
then will fessed up to mike
it was the seventh huh the rule it was a
seven
the demogorgon it got me of course
foreshadowing the demogorgon about to
get will and maybe about to get
these kids and then papa brenner greets
them as 11
panics from her room i'm glad to hear it
because today i have something very
special planned for you
you're listening i think the voice here
could be that of a teacher or a doctor
to 11
in the present day as she gets triggered
back into the memory of this trauma from
the hawkins lab
and now that she no longer has her
powers she may be suffering some panic
attacks that she no longer has a way to
defend herself and her loved ones if any
of these threats ever return
comment down below with your thoughts
and theories and support this channel by
checking out one of our great merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
subscribe to new rockstars and
breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you